it was life before 9/11 and there's life
after 9/11 in life after 9/11 is
actually quite different
Pam bourbon and before we got to today
just a quick reminder to subscribe to
our channel and click the little bell so
they actually see our videos and now
more importantly joining me today is the
former anchor of ABC's World News Now
and CNN's news night as well as a former
professor at the Walter Cronkite School
of Journalism and mass communication at
Arizona State University
Aaron Brown welcome to the Reuben report
thank you thank you I am really glad to
have you obviously this week is the
anniversary of 9/11 and when I got to
know you and I think when millions of
other people got to know you was on
September 11th 2001 you were anchoring
cnn's morning coverage that morning but
she probably thought was just going to
be like any other morning and then very
quickly it was not there was a rumor out
there that you've already started
correcting me before we started here but
that was actually your first day at CNN
but you're telling me that's not the
case no it's such a good story and you
know I don't know how many times I've
been interviewed I don't know how many
times this has come up I don't know how
many times I said honestly I love this
story too I wish it was true but it's
not and it's such a good story that they
would write it anyway so how did that
come to be that people thought that that
was reverse morning sorry how did that
come to be that people thought that that
was your first morning on CNN well I'm
not sure I know if I were to guess you
know there are days and there are days
and I had been doing I mean I ain't
heard the weekend show I did 29 lines a
year I was on television a fair amount
in my life but none of those days is
9/11 and so all of a sudden this kind of
funny-looking dude
glasses shows up on your TV screen on
the biggest day in your country's modern
history and you say well that's not
Peter and that's not Dan and that's not
Tom and I've never seen this funny look
I did before you must be new and I
honestly think that's what happened that
it wasn't that it you know on an average
night CNN and you'll probably had a
million people watching the president
stem-cell speech President Bush's
stem-cell speech which I incurred was in
August maybe a million people watched
that twenty million people in America
watch 9/11
one and a quarter billion people around
the world watch CNN and four from
September 11th to Thanksgiving I was on
TV I mean I you you couldn't avoid me I
was like a disease and I was constantly
there I was on TV eight hours a day
every day until we finally finally went
home to my wife and kid and with one
away for Thanksgiving weekend so I just
think the newness of it all probably
helped create the myth but you know what
that's the worst myth there is about you
I can live with that
yeah that's pretty good all right well
hopefully we've dispelled that fake news
for all the time but but let's talk
about that morning so obviously you had
had plenty of other jobs in broadcasting
well before that and anchoring and all
sorts of things but clearly there was
nothing that could possibly prepare you
for what was going to happen that
morning as 8:47 rolled around what what
was it like that morning well I mean it
was crazy
III don't know that I'd necessarily say
nothing can prepare you for that because
that's actually in a kind of literal way
true nothing you've never dealt with the
attack on your country all of these
things at 9/11 was all of that's true on
the other hand I thought I think I
prepared my whole life for that day I
had no one wants that day but if there's
going to be a day like that I wanted to
be the person to tell the story
I felt capable of telling the story I
understood the magnitude of the story I
had done the 93 World Trade Center
bombing by Al Qaeda
I felt like knew what was happening at
the same time I'm not gonna lie to you I
mean there's a there's that little part
of every guy who's going do not screw
this up and do not make this worse this
is a horrible day in your country's
history and the last thing we need is
for you to do something stupid um so
that was there yeah so the main thing
and the reason why I wanted to have you
on and I've actually been trying to
track you down for for quite some time
is that as someone that lived in New
York City during 9/11 I mean all of us
you know we would go out for groceries
but basically beyond that we were we
were glued to the television and not
just people that lived in New York City
everybody that lived in America and
really across the world but there was
something about your demeanor
there was a calmness and a decency to it
that is so I would say the complete 180
of so much of what cable news has become
now and I'm wondering is that just
something that is sort of personally
part of who you are is that sort of what
you wanted your television persona to be
or did it you all just sort of unfurl as
live yes thank you
I mean I take that as a compliment I
don't know that I ever there was a
period when
ABC when I thought I had a television
persona and it was horrible I mean I was
honestly I you know it was it was I
thought I was supposed to be Peter
I admired Peter I thought I was supposed
to be more formal than I am I'm just a
guy from a small town in Minnesota yeah
I think I'm at my best or was at my best
when I was just me and I am actually
fairly called I don't I'm not much of a
hyper you know I don't like I don't want
to use any one's as an example but um I
don't use the word dramatic very often I
don't tell people this is gonna be
dramatic it's if it's dramatic to them
as dramatic to them why don't ya do you
remember feeling the pressure though as
as that first plane hit and it was still
unclear whether it was a terrorist
attack do you remember feeling the
inherent pressure I mean not the first
plane yet I wasn't on TV so I don't know
on the second plane when the sand plane
had I knew what was happening
yeah first plane I thought I don't know
maybe maybe somebody had a heart attack
I don't mean I'd come into LaGuardia
hundreds of times and you come up to you
would come up the river and you'd go
past the Trade Center and I thought well
I don't know I mean crazy stuff happens
somebody crashed into the building when
the second plane here then there was no
question anymore right I I said this is
a attack on the country this is al-qaeda
you know what else has to wherewithal to
pull off something like this this is a
this is the there wasn't a war on terror
as such but this is the war on terror
beginning this is it
you know what's it like being in a
newsroom in in those moments when
something truly horrific is happening
someone who's in the newsroom well
they're funny they're funneling
information to you and here I know that
for example I mean I was on the roof of
the building of our building on 38 8th
and it wasn't a studio they were trying
to throw up lights and just crazy stuff
was going on I'm afraid of heights and
guys are on scaffolding so I'm afraid
someone's gonna it was nuts in the
control room I was pretty sure was crazy
cuz I've been in control rooms but the
controller's job case you don't know you
probably do know this is the guy I don't
know it yeah right
however crazy they are at a given moment
they do not transmit that insanity to
you because what you need to know is
information and that everything is under
control
it's not yeah and there's some of you
that knows it's not the things that
we're supposed to work aren't working
that someone who is supposed to be ready
isn't that somebody says something
stupid you're gonna have to correct all
those things are going on they're
yelling at each other remember when I
was doing the weekend show it ABC and I
brought my daughter and she was probably
7 or 8 years old maybe a little older
and she was in the control room and
after the show she came down and she she
was a seven eight year old with why
should she be shown not that she cared
that her dad was doing the TV show it
was just the magic and she said dad you
know they say the f-word up there yeah I
think there are two different places
there's the place I occupied which I
owned
I own that space the the people there
were reflective of my emotional state
and supported my emotional state which
was calm and there's that other world
the newsroom which was crazy the control
room which is insane everybody who's
making there's Atlanta which is wanting
control of the show there's all sorts of
crazy stuff going on none of which has
to do with the fact that 3,000 of my
countrymen are dying so despite your
your calm demeanor and the
professionalism did you ever have
moments where you thought you were gonna
just break up while on air I mean I
remember there were moments in days and
weeks after where people people would
just be crying on the street you know I
was playing basketball at your Gracie
Mansion a couple weeks later a bunch of
us were finally went out to run around
and then then one guy just started
crying on the basketball court well you
know that's no no is the short answer
when the day was over which was about
1:30 in the morning
the Wednesday morning so we had done
about 18 hours of television whatever it
was I was tired and I was spent I
desperately had to pee and I just sat
down they thought they were worried
about me which I thought was crazy and
wept because I knew what you know what
we all know which was that our world had
changed that our world was not gonna be
the same I knew that my daughter's life
was going to be different I didn't I
don't mean any of that in a personal way
which weirdly is also true but but that
life has there was life before 9/11 and
there's life after 9/11 in life after
9/11 is actually quite different I mean
we have come to make
normal is normal to walk through
airports and look around and go through
security and this and that another thing
and it's normal to go into all these
buildings and have them check your bags
and thought that all this crazy stuff is
normal it's normal to hear that someone
died in Afghanistan that's crazy that
happened the other day they're still
dying in Afghanistan normal to us but it
wasn't normal on the 10th of September
2001 yeah
did you very quickly realize how how
much was gonna change no I wish I wish I
was as smart as people's somehow think I
know I thought I knew but end of the day
I mean I've talked to a lot of people
I've interviewed a lot of people people
I mean I knew we were going to war and
that but the small stuff I mean there's
the big stuff we're going to war that's
big just little stuff that post 9/11 is
our lives so we none of us thought about
I don't think but became I don't know I
mean you were in New York you know yeah
what do you remember about when you were
off camera being in New York that's kind
of normal
except on September 12th it is totally
terrified yeah what do you remember
about about just life in New York when
you when you were off camera I wasn't
necessarily a happy New Yorker before
9/11 it's where I worked I was honored
to have the jobs
for sure but almost kind of a small-town
guy post-911
I thought I started to understand the
New York better that it didn't seem
quite as balkanized to me that I did see
a sense of community that I hadn't seen
or appreciated was for I felt more a
part of it I felt better about about it
I was I was proud of my fellow New
Yorkers and I was proud of how the
country took New Yorkers into their
bosom and and tried to help them heal
those of us who lived through it no man
I I drove up to go home when that
finally became part of my life I would
drive up eighth Avenue past the Port
Authority as fire station
[Music]
4650 and I would periodically stop in
there they had had a terribly late they
had taken a terrible loss and I would
bring them stuff or just sit around you
to the crap this and that and I thought
I don't no one will ever hear a fire
engine the same again no one will ever
see a fireman in New York the same again
I mean that's what I meant by all the
little things that change you know and
if you live there and you know this you
live there do you appreciate that it is
the little things that those people
stole from us and they still 3,000 lives
and they they did a lot of things but
they also stole the comfort of
day-to-day living and sometimes I think
that's the most unforgivable part yeah
it was in a weird way I mean it's it's
almost twisted
think about it this way but there was
sort of a magical period in New York for
a certain time after 9/11 because of the
way we we all kind of treated each other
and cars were honking Lessing people
were people were nicer and I absolutely
agree with that I think there was a
magical time in America that started on
9/11 and ended probably you know March
19th 2003 when we went to war Iraq I
thought that period in between we we
understood way better our common
connections and you know the
disagreements over what happened kind of
split us again which is and we we we
have not and I'm not quite sure how we
will recover from that that seemed to be
the beginning of this kind of polarizing
period so speaking of the polarizing
period despite your calm demeanor can
you talk a little bit about when you're
when you're live on air and and
something's happening you know something
let the level of 9/11 or or far less
significant what it's like when when
news is rushing in and you've got the
IFB in and the control-room guys are
telling you things on the fly just
making sure that what you're saying is
actually accurate as we live in this
time of fake news where nobody trusts
anything and you know anchors botched
things constantly and you know news
reports are wrong all the time or
slightly misleading or whatever you are
the the headline is seemingly different
than the the article itself just the
type of pressure it is to just be
getting information from the control
room and actually making sure you're
accurately representing it well first of
all I'm going to answer the question but
I'm going to answer the question without
agreeing to all of the characterizations
sure I I don't that's not how I see the
news business today and how do you today
I mean talk about that sure I don't you
know that's not a problem for me but let
me answer the specific question first um
I I trust I trust the people I work with
the people at ABC and the people at CNN
busted their asses every second of every
day to get it right
and I knew that because I did it - and I
trust myself I trust myself in part
because I've learned my lessons from
Peter really well don't get head of a
story okay the story is a story you
don't don't speculate don't get ahead of
it but I also trust that I know the
difference between someone's excitement
and someone is verified something no one
who's done breaking news has gotten
through it no one ever in the history of
humans has gone through breaking news
and done everything right you can't do
17 hours of television live and get
every word right what you can do is
correct it when you don't I remember
that we reported we reported the State
Department had been evacuated we turned
out not to be true but someone reported
that and you fix it you corrected that
no one was being malicious in reporting
that it happens live TV is is walking on
a tightrope without a net and in in
those moments in the big moments it yeah
that rope is really small I want you to
address the the way I frame the question
though but very quickly for people that
don't know the Peter that you're
referring to obviously is Peter Jennings
who is the the legendary ABC news anchor
for four decades Peter would work for
Peter Peter was important to me Peter is
best and cry
I saw my remember I was pretty new at
ABC and he was doing a special report no
sitting them and those are watching them
cause this is Schmo from Seattle been
hired by ABC could be overnight newsmen
yeah i watch Peter and I thought oh my
god he is so much better than I I just
he was an unbelievable talent and his
his passing is something that I think
about all the time well yeah so wait
let's let's back up to the way I frame
that question about how there there
seems to be at least so this is from you
know I'm on the online side of this and
there's definitely a feeling that that
mainstream news is not as reliable as it
once was or that it's become very
sensationalistic or that you know the
cable news specifically they're
constantly competing for ratings so it's
more over the top and more over the top
and more over the top do you not agree
with that premise do you not do you not
see it that way well I mean if I could
break down every sentence I'd say well I
agree with that and I disagree with that
for example do do cable networks compete
yeah they and the time competes with the
post and the Dodgers compete with the
Yankees I mean competition is at the
core of much of what we do but the fact
that we compete in whatever it is we
compete in doesn't necessarily mean it
is not by definition some terrible thing
it in many cases I think it makes us
better yeah I thought I mean because I
thought one of the things about network
TV about ABC CBS and ABC competing
against those people which and I thought
my god these people they're really good
they're bad ones are really good I
thought I was so out of my league I
thought at first it was crazy I wanted
to beat them I want I wanted I wanted to
be first
I wanted to be better I wanted to write
better I wanted to produce better no
differently then you wanted to ask
better questions then whoever it is do
you compete with so the fact that we
compete it's just the fact that we
compete it doesn't
III think I don't want to go on
endlessly on this but I do know it's a
couple things I'd like to say sure one
is if I look at my 35 years I would
identify two things that I think are
significantly different beyond the one
thing that is totally different which is
technology yeah technology is hugely
different in it I won't say it doesn't
change things it changes everything but
I don't think this it changes substance
and in quite the way other people like
so let me say the two things that I see
one is when I started doing this we had
a shared set of facts we all agreed that
the earth was round mm-hmm
there wasn't a flat earth channel today
it seems to me then we we don't have a
shared set of facts you get to have your
facts I don't understand that but that
just seems to be the way Jake's is
people don't like these facts well come
up with my own facts okay I like those
better you know strong disco does go to
Alabama well actually you know we can
spend it with talking about something
that's stupid so that's number one in
the significance of that to me is when
we agreed on the fact we still thought
but we fought a kind of substantive
fight about how to deal with poverty
what's the best way we didn't
you know whether there was there there
was there were conservative ideas and
liberal ideas and modern ideas on how to
deal with it and we would fight about
which of those ideas would get us to
where we wanted to go we understood
where we wanted to go I see this in
health care debate where people could
get friendly she's a friend of ice crazy
she is crazy
um he was a doctor and he said well in
the old days everybody got treatment and
I'm thinking no that's crazy
that's crazy you were a doctor you want
his orthopedic surgeon you aren't
putting artificial or play shoulder
replacements in poor people you weren't
doing it this for fun no but he's
convinced himself of his set of facts
the other thing that's different and
that I think is really dangerous is to
many many of us Americans or whatever
too many of us only want to hear that
which we already believe is true and I
don't I to do the kind of show you do
you have to read a lot you can't just
read the little things that support what
you believe is true you have to have
some sense of what other people believe
and how they approach things and and so
that's what I do
I mean I I've done it all my life I
cannot die reading some crazy thing
because that's what I do I want to know
what the Wall Street Journal says in
this editorial page in the same way I
want to know at the time septoria page
says I want to know what actual review
online says I've had some really
interesting ideas have come out of the
conservative press in the neo-cons what
I find interesting group of people and I
also find the progressive press
interesting is a little
tedious but nevertheless interesting and
most people I'm going to use the Fox
word now if you're if it's that true
it's also your politics you turn Fox on
and I've seen the ratings I know this is
actually true it's if you're competing
against those guys it's a [ __ ] that's
how they want how do we get out of that
that that funneling of you know self
self-imposed prison prison basically no
that's a that's a great question and
honestly you have to put someone way
smarter than me I'm just you know I'm
just a guy that wrote the news reported
stories I don't know the answer maybe
the first part of the answer is we have
to understand better how we got into it
you know I mean at some point if you
don't understand why you've got lost
you'd never get out of the forest and my
concern is and I don't know the answer
to that I'm not pretending to know the
answer there I can pick spots where I I
thought how that person is just upset
with me because we were worded something
that is factually true they're not just
purely in the facts but they don't like
the fact and and I would get I would try
and answer 50 emails a day and mostly
you're just saying thanks or I'm sorry
we disagree or you know whatever and and
sometimes people would write about this
I can't believe that you reported this
story I mean yeah it happened well you
don't have to report it it makes us look
bad doesn't you know don't you feel
better having been in a society where
people know everything
as opposed to just little bits of things
yeah I mean we you're doing this amazing
to me amen we talked a little before
about the fact I've never done anything
quite like this and you're working it's
technology that didn't exist a
generation of them and we carry around I
have my little phone here yeah we carry
around in our pockets the sum total of
knowledge of the human race if we wanted
you know if we're connected to the
Internet we have all of this knowledge
and information available to us but we
only want to hear the stuff that makes
us feel good doesn't say that's insane I
mean that actually is basically why I'm
doing this show and why I try to get on
people from the left and the right and
pretty much everywhere else because yeah
we're catering it to ourselves and then
we wonder why we're polarized yeah you
know I don't
I wish I had the answer I wish I could
snap my fingers and make people read the
editorial of the op-eds of this or that
or another thing I wish I could say to
them instead of watching this channel
today watch that Channel today and I
some time working for the Mayo
foundation doing work about healthcare
and healthcare reform I I didn't know
anything really about it but learned a
lot and one things I learned really a
lot of good ideas that don't those what
you know progressives have a lot of good
ideas and conservatives have a lot of
good ideas and none of them seem to be
perfect ideas but if if we're only
listening to one set of ideas we're
missing another set of ideas that may
help us get there I mean if if we have a
shared goal of making sure that every
one of our fellow citizens has health
affordable health care then why wouldn't
we
listen to every responsible idea to make
that hat and traveling around the
country for mail help me understand that
that there were lots of ways to do it
and some of them work some of them doing
some of them have big-time flaws frankly
to me you might not think your flaws but
I think this loss you know someone else
might not think their flaws but I think
and this is where it's supposed to be
we're supposed to have a set of values
that we think are important and then we
find ideas that help us achieve those
things like that here's a crazy man
I think every American child should have
a good school I'm embarrassed
our mediocrity mm-hmm how can I say to
America have mediocre public schools
that's insane
so that's a value of my or I'm truly
embarrassed that a child born today in
Havana Cuba is more likely to reach her
first birthday than a child born today
in Washington DC that's crazy
I'm an American that's not supposed to
have that's a value of mine so I would
put money in there I fix them I don't
know how I'd fix it I mean I'm not that
smart but look at other things yeah do
you remember when cable news sort of
like a moment or a period of time when
it started getting more sensationalistic
because I do remember when when you were
on CNN and and Larry King was on CNN
there was there was a sense I one of the
things when I was doing a little
research on you the phrase cerebral came
up a couple times and it's like when I
think there was a time when you watch
cable news and you actually felt that
you were gonna learn something you were
gonna get a little smarter and now and
we don't have to pick a network I won't
pick on anybody but generally what I
find when I watch cable news
I don't feel smarter I got a partisan
talking point why do I
well I don't watch that much to be quite
honest but I watch you know little bites
here and there that I usually get
through Twitter do you not watch I don't
watch much no I don't watch much TV
part of it is unseen sausage get amazing
I mean there's some a little bit of that
part of it is it's hard to watch as a
civilian you know I did it for 35 years
so it's hard not to say well I'd have
done this or why would you you know
there's some of that but it's also just
stunningly inefficient yeah I'm just a
little retired guy at me I sound like
I'm that busy or anything but um if I
want to see something I I just you know
google it and I can see it honestly and
and if I want to read something I know
how to find the stuff I want to read it
here there and everywhere
um so on you know in a weird way I find
modern television inefficient for
someone like me I don't
i-i'll agree with I'm not much of a food
fight person you know to have a pan I
mean it's the only I love I loved and
I'm grateful to CNN I wouldn't have the
life I have if it were not see any I
don't know why they gave me that much
money but God bless so I can sit here in
Santa Fe New Mexico and the in the wet
in the summer and have this conversation
I'm grateful for them they have these
panels of like a thousand people and the
goal seems to be if they could get 500
of them to talk and wise I don't find
that interesting I don't I I don't enter
I didn't interview that way
I didn't want occasionally I'd have to
but I liked one and sometimes producers
would say you know it'd be kind of fun
if we did this they try and it's
probably why you know I wasn't that
successful because I didn't appreciate
the food fight I was trying to elicit
serious answers about serious questions
and if I spotted a serious hypocrisy I
was certainly gonna go at that I liked I
didn't I didn't mind confrontation on TV
at all but I just find this cut and I
think everybody does it kind of a staged
confrontation I'm not crazy about yeah I
have to back you up so you just said
that's probably why you weren't that
successful I mean you were you were
incredibly successful but but do you
mean that if you had done that more that
maybe CNN you know doesn't bring in
Anderson Cooper and and you know
Newsnight with Aaron Brown is still on
15 years later yeah you know maybe I
mean it is things happen because they're
supposed to happen and that was okay I
was I was pretty ready but I actually
the decision it's it's funny I was
thinking about this today I thought I
didn't know if we it just was the
direction we'd go but there was John
rrah of stories in my ear maybe there
still is but it doesn't seem like it now
all stories are trump stories all trump
all the time well just he did this he
did he is not he's this he's okay in my
in one of the stories of my Europe it
was the missing white girl story a
little white girl some usually cute well
they don't won the big one right before
9/11 was Chandra Levy which I'm sure you
remember that that was like these story
until 9/11 yes and she wasn't a blonde
but she was missing and that had some
it was the oldest member thinking when I
was doing the Santa deal are you really
prepared to do this night after night
and it turned out I didn't have to so
there is a god but there was a young
woman and some horrible stories tragic
terrible but not national story named
Natalie Holloway yes I think from
Alabama or something and she went on a
senior trip and she disappeared and she
got killed and it was horrible it's fun
it was a not a national story there was
though larger issue that it wasn't an
epidemic of missing white girls it
wasn't but viewers liked those stories
like weather stories viewers liked those
stories and I did not like them and part
of it was just stubborn I can be very
stubborn and I thought this is stupid
and it's pandering and would we do this
if it was a missing black girl and the
answer is no and Greta god bless her was
all over it I mean all over at all
Natalie all the time and I refused to do
it and I had bosses who said you should
do this story I just I have to I have
got a contractual right to make this
decision and I'm making it and the news
night whatever bra has not gonna do the
story
so then you don't do that story and then
I assume that that hurts ratings and
that is that really ultimately what kind
of kind of burns it out
just only yes it absolutely it was a
thank you for lawyers call an adverse
interest the probably the show well it's
the interesting question this argument
the show would have gone better
the counter-argument which is the one I
comfortably lived with
is that I could put off the viewers
would know
now they yours would know this is not
Aaron Brown this is not who he is
she's more tedious than that he's more
boring than that he's horse smurfiest
that man he's more cerebral if that's a
word or whatever it is they wouldn't
have bought it from me and I felt that
pretty strongly and I also felt that I
had one thing to sell and that was
authenticity that I am an authentic
person and if I lost that I really had
nothing is it I don't want anyone ever
to think I was being a hero or that I
was standing up for journalism with a
capital J or any of that it was
self-preservation
I and and maybe selfishness because I
had people work for me um I had a
reputation that I value I dreamed it and
I wasn't gonna do anything that I
thought would damage it part of the
reason I never really wanted to work
after that this I was very happy with
how people thought of me I don't know
yeah but you do it you did a couple
shows after that but then but then ended
it you taught for seven years at Arizona
State
yeah and that was fun I mean that was I
mean I never went to college and so I
always would tell students is my college
experience get drunk later I'll tell you
story you know you can cut this out I'm
cool we love that go for it which we
never added for content on this show I
held back on one of my rules feel free
to break the rule if you want because
it's it's it's a it's kind of a weird
pat on the back story but I don't quite
that way um this happened about two
weeks ago three weeks ago me and my wife
and I were walking we had had dinner and
we were leaving the restaurant she saw
someone she knew and she introduced me
to this woman and the woman introduced
me to her husband and it was about my
age I would say and he said I always
wanted to meet you because and I've had
that conversation a billion times and I
know what comes next
and he was gonna say I was in Dublin a
911 and blah blah blah
somebody said she said the 9th of George
Harrison dog you did the most amazing
program and I've always wanted to just
thank you for it I had no idea what it
but anyone who works in television or
whatever we call television now ok no no
the thing is yeah notice how ephemeral
it all is I mean you do it it's out
there it's gone under the next thing but
a generation later that George Harrison
died I looked this up
November 30th 2001 so we're talking
almost a generation later he remembered
what I did and he actually quoted the
first line of the show which was really
weird ok well I would give I'll give you
this word he said you started the show
by saying I read the news today and the
news was rather sad and we talked he
remembered a lot of it I ended up
getting them the show but I didn't
remember any of it my point in the story
telling the story is not our time
wonderful though I think that is I know
that at various moments of my life the
work I did can
to people in ways I don't even
appreciate and then 20 years later I'm
the most anonymous person on the planet
I go out of my way to be just me is not
easy - it was not easy to track you down
to do this but I thank you for
responding
I appreciate whatever effort I wasn't
trying to be difficult I didn't know you
were looking I value I don't think
anyone ever says you know I remember the
work he did on Natalie Holloway yeah I
guess I just want to protect that I want
to protect I wanted to protect the sense
that people respected the work I did
yeah if it I waited a long time for one
of those jobs I wasn't the natural I
didn't I didn't beat I you know I didn't
get that job thought I was in my 50s I
had done a lot I had had a life I had I
was I was what would call him golf a
grinder
I just you couldn't kill me that was
unkillable it's funny I read a piece
where you described it you described
anchors as leading men as character
actors and it's so interesting to me
because because of that authenticity
which is just it was it was obvious then
and it was obvious now so it's almost
like you you did all this work and then
almost stumbled into the anchor things
somehow I was you know in the analogy
earth the description I mean Peter was a
leading man yeah I mean yeah Peter
looked like he was born in a trench coat
I mean I saw him once I saw him I used
to live on the Upper West Side by ABC
News over there and I saw him walking
down the street and he looked like a
leading man I mean everything about him
the way he stood his hair his face
everything after Rockland I mean he
that's who
I was Peter Falk I wasn't supposed to
have a leading man's job
except they didn't count on I had this I
have a talent I can write and I can talk
to people I guess and I had
determination that I could be done and I
it's whether that was the you know we
can debate whether I was good at it or
not good at or III don't even know
sometimes but I know I wasn't a leading
man I know it was a real guy I I was I
did have a kind of boy-next-door quality
and when I settled that that's who I was
going to be that the Aaron Brown on
television was going to be earned brown
lost television good things happen to me
yeah it's like you're giving me
one-on-one advice right now basically
people watching be yourselves it's all
you can do are you know one of the
questions I get most when I when I tour
and I go to colleges and things I find
this really at college is more than
anywhere else
students will ask me who I trust who do
I trust in the media who do you trust
in the media these needs on your answer
well usually I tell them it's it's rare
that I trust an institution anymore so I
can't say that I trust CNN anymore or I
even trust the New York Times anymore
there are some specific writers that I
like there are a couple online people
that I that I really like that are off
the beaten path but I it's it's becoming
increasingly harder and harder to find
television personalities I suppose that
I that I really trust do you do you have
a list now there are a couple people you
can recommend for the college kids that
are watching I I don't know I mean I
there are a lot of people who write for
both posted the times well I think as
reporters
as someone who is in some cases competed
against them and in some case the cases
that I'm glad I didn't compete against
them I think are terrific of me in this
moment that you and I are talking okay
just it's a great little example of
something
Jodie canter and Megan chewy artery in
the country promoting their book on the
Harvey Weinstein story which is really a
story of investigative journalism and
how they can to write the story and we
can fuss about me too and that as much
we haven't settled in me to which i
think is true but we can't argue the
journalism of that story the new web
pharaoh also deserves a big pat on the
back for his work so i look at the the
news environment differently I think
than perhaps you do I see a lot of
people whose work I admire and I part of
it is there's so much there's so much
out there it's like you go to a
restaurant and you actually only eat
like two things but there's like 20
things in the menu go to Cheesecake
Factory there's like a Faust things on
the menu that baby is too big it's like
a book you know they can't do a thousand
things well you know that nobody can do
that no restaurant can do I feel a
little bit that way about the news is
that there's so much media out there
something that's gonna be bad
unhealthful to caloric but the there's
gonna be some of it the degree and the
the challenge for the consumer it seems
to me getting back to an earlier
part of our conversation is not to stop
going to the Cheesecake Factory dog
believe me not recommending that to
anyone it is to find the people who make
sense to you
and if crisp como is not one of those
people that are watching as I have a
food I had a friend who used to watch
television he ate it so he could get
angry I said nicely sure I said why you
know don't do that life's too short
watch stuff that actually makes you feel
smarter or better informed or challenges
you or something you know and I I think
but in a general way unless maybe it's
because I'm older I'm way less cynical
about modern media that you I I hope
you're right I really do
I generally don't mean that I I feel
right I I wonder how people would look
at for example the post and the times in
this period where I've seen a ton of
fabulous journalism and almost none of
it has been questioned a lot of it
people go because it's a phrase of the
moment well as fake news but what they
actually mean is I don't like it nothing
that's wrong I mean does anybody any
serious person believe that the times
right stuff it just makes it up there
really you believe I got one for you did
you happen to see about two months ago
the cover of The Sunday Times there was
a it was the cover the front page of the
Sunday Times was a picture about how
youtubers are radicalizing people to the
far right and the all right and one of
the pictures that they had in there was
my picture I mean I'm a liberal my whole
life I have these types of conversations
so they've done some strange things I
would leave it at that but believe me
hope you're right I don't tell him piss
me off okay
I mean that would totally pissed me off
and and I would and I would I like that
I live in a euro I can't say pissed off
on television you can say other than
that if you want I'm sure I can't really
you know I have this reputation
he's cerebral he was no sir he really
yeah
don't blow right now you don't want to
blow it on YouTube you know oh I don't I
I'm the kind of person who would cause a
copy editor would find the copy other I
mean I just I had a problem with DIRECTV
two weeks ago I called the president of
a those of AT&T cuz they just won't fix
it and I figured well you want to get it
fixed call him yeah
I actually don't think that New York
Times has a public editor anymore but I
did they I did invite the I did invite
the author on the show many times and he
declined the author of the article so my
point is that if at any point look all
of us who are public people have things
said about us or written about us that
we would find troubling I have a friend
who's in the middle of a retu mess and
he's just and in one level breaks my
heart that he put himself in that
situation on their level I thought I
know what it's like to have people who
beat you up in public that's terrible
you got Akana
it's like the yin and the yang you get
to do this really cool job you could be
you know putting doors on Ford Focuses
but instead you get to interview anyone
you want to interview I mean that's
really cool so you take a little hit but
but if that's the worst thing you've
gone on the times if that's the worst
thing you got on the times I'm not
saying it was right
I'm not saying that they should have
done it I am not saying you shouldn't be
pissed off about it I'm saying if that's
the worst thing you got a photo editor
made a stupid decision come on I can
give you a couple of others but I'll
spare you
they also get to read Peter Baker or
Maggie Haberman I mean there's a lot of
you know no institution is perfect
no none even yours no institution is
probably some people say it was his
first day on the job you know people
screw up well listen on that note you
know I know that you're you're basically
off the grid these days and you don't do
social media or any of that stuff and
and I wanted to fly you out here to LA
are you doing I couldn't find you what's
your Twitter handle Brown 11:10
Aaron Brown 11:10 I we couldn't we
couldn't hunt that one down all right
I'm gonna follow you on Twitter and I'll
get you some Twitter followers and I'll
get you some Twitter followers and then
you're gonna be right back in the mess
no I believe me I am NOT gonna be in the
mess you only get in the mess if you
choose to be in a mess and you and you
know I've chosen not to there you go
well listen right I seriously appreciate
the conversation and I thought that the
questions were good the push backs were
fun and maybe this won't make sense to
you but does to me I'm glad I said yes
I'm glad you said yes to you listen you
you walked America through a through a
time that was crazy and I think a little
bit of that decency that resonated with
me is what I've tried to bring to what I
do here so I thank you I hope we can we
can do this in person at some but I'll
come to Santa Fe that's how we're gonna
do it next entry that's agree it's a
great place Thank You Aaron thank you so
much I really appreciate it very well
[Music]